[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  what-whatever than that has been safely  hidden for 2,000 years  this isn't a - ed - prison Nick  the hieroglyph said she was named our  Minette chosen to be Egypt's next queen  but her thirst for power led her down a  darker parcel one that had to be stopped  [Music]  [Applause]  because of your actions  this ancient power  has returned  [Music]  you are alive because you were chosen  sure but what evil  the ultimate evil  legend has it she's a being of  unimaginable powers now she's using him  to regain them  she will not stop until she has remade  our world into her own  we should stay with me is get my figure  massage you can't run  you can't escape  she's got plans for you  [Music]